ihr müsst kurz auf mein niveau runter
und damit herzlich willkommen warum
mache ich eigentlich mit den hier immer
zu begrüßen wie so ein captain so mo 1
und damit herzlich willkommen wir heute
meine lieben freunde zu einer neuen
episode von geiles jahr keine episode
möchte das gar nicht so häufig mache
aber ich beantworte heute mal ein paar
fragen die ich mir auf instagram
gestellt habt ich hasse laser lukas wenn
ihr auch fragen stellen wollen für
nächstes video sofort begannen aber
gerade super cooles foto hochgeladen
allerdings würde ich sagen starten wir
jetzt auch schon mit den fragen warum
stehst du bist hier her perfekte danke
für eure fragen heizen teigwaren
teigwaren weil sie mal teigwaren könnt
ihr mir nicht einfach vernünftige fragen
stellen warst du schon immer so hässlich
auch da kann ich mich wirklich nur
bedanken wann kommt die nächste treue
hot to handle reaktion ich glaube du
meinst du holztür hände man lieber peter
parker 8422 und die kommt morgen
was ist dein lieblingslied airwaves höre
ich gerade morgens bis abends die ganze
zeit querbeet durch kannst du mehr
videos mit max machen da sind auf jeden
fall einige videos geplant die sache ist
nur dass wir gerade aufgrund von corona
halt nicht so richtig bloggen dürfen
also dürfen wir schon aber man kann
nicht so coole sachen machen und da habe
ich halt coole pläne auch mit max aber
wir müssen ein bisschen warten bis ich
die ganze lage beruhigt hat aber kommt
bald auf jeden fall ich will auch meinen
ganzen umzug nach hamburg locken und
damit kommen jetzt auch schon zur
nächsten frage wann genau ziehst du nach
hamburg und warum eigentlich ich ziehe
mitte juli nach hamburg also in circa
eineinhalb monaten die sache das
allerdings und das habe ich auch schon
im podcast gesagt dass das kein
richtiger umzug wird im sinne von ich
packe alle meine sachen bereue alles
nach hamburg bringen das dahin und dann
wohne ich dort nee ich werde die ganze
zeit noch ein bisschen pendeln ich werde
viele sachen hier auch in köln lassen
vieles aber auch mit dem nach hamburg da
bin ich halt an beiden orten immer so
ein bisschen sein kann wo ich war grade
lieber sein möchte und der grund ist ein
bisschen tapetenwechsel
aber auch investitionen natürlich klar
immobilie
und bock ist auch einfach eine ziemlich
coole stadt machst du bald eine ruptur
cleese in der neuen wohnung bitte ich
bin endlich nicht so ein riesen fan von
wurden ich weiß dass man sich das mega
mega gerne anschaut und das auch immer
coole videos sind und ich mich selber
daher auch kraß für interessiere für
architektur für wohnungen et cetera aber
ich habe ein bisschen angst wegen
privatsphäre und ich schau mal soll
nichts böses seien aber könntest du
julia und bibi krasses haus weil im
video was du vor ein paar und weil die
frage vorbei klar ich könnte den das
100% das habe ich auch im video gesagt
wirklich tausendprozentig könig denen
das die haben sich das alles selbst
erarbeitet das komplette geld und wenn
die das in eine immobilie stecken
beziehungsweise in ein haus in köln bin
ich der erste der sagt ich könnte euch
das zu 100% die bude ist hammer ich
hätte ein paar sachen anders gemacht als
halt geschmackssache aber 1000 prozentig
können nicht dass wir würden ich denen
das hat welches auto fährst du
wie soll das nächste limitierte item aus
dem luca - shop.de ca aussehen keine
ahnung um wie viel uhr kommt die neue
podcast folge online immer montags und
donnerstags um null uhr
also wenn ihr montags und donnerstags
aufsteht und zur schule fahrt oder arno
dann ist auf jeden fall eine neue folge
online ärgerst du dich noch an seinen
ersten kuss
ich glaube ich hatte noch nie ein wie
stehst du zu dem ganzen thema rassismus
und dass das so präsent ist momentan ich
finde es extrem traurig dass wir im
verdammten jahr 2020 leben und rassismus
und rassendiskriminierung ezb so krass
war bei einigen dummen menschen im kopf
verankert ist das ist einfach das ist es
ist zum kotzen finde ich dass ich habe
heute das hier in meiner instagram story
gepasst wir waren heute auf der demo
hier in köln auf der anti rassismus
thema und ist also da gibt es einfach
keine zwei meinungen was ist deine
meinung zu dem stand in amerika gerade
ich finde es richtig dass er jetzt so
eine krasse bewegung raus geworden ist
und es ist auch anscheinend immer noch
leider notwendig auch wenn wir im
verdammten jahr 2020 leben aber ich
finde es echt beängstigend was das
mittlerweile für ausmaße mit sich zieht
wie lange brauchst du für die videos zu
drehen und schneiden kommt tatsächlich
auf video an also jetzt hier schon
fragen video das man sich relativ
schnell fertig irgendwie insgesamt in
zwei stunden zweieinhalb stunden oder so
will ich sagen aber wenn ich
beispielsweise blogs mache oder gaming
videos sich kraft verarbeitet dann kann
schon mal irgendwie so vier stunden
dauern
viereinhalb stunden oder so wenn es eine
vierte pizza geben würde wie würdest du
sie dir vorstellen habe ich absolut
keine ahnung
es wird auf jeden fall wieder irgendwas
kreatives denke ich mal wie lange machst
du noch youtube die frage bekomme ich
tatsächlich mega häufig gestellt
allerdings kann ich wirklich nur immer
die gleiche antwort geben und zwar genau
so lange wie es mir noch spaß macht weil
so hat es gestartet als hobby der damals
überhaupt kein geld mit verdient die
ersten ein zwei jahre
aber ja
wenn ich mir keinen spaß mehr mache dann
mache ich es nicht mehr auf liebst du
deine fans nee ich hasse euch alle
ja klar natürlich ich meine hier seit
der grund warum ich das ganze hier auf
vom level machen kann als man es
eigentlich hier würde ich sagen ich
würde sagen so machen jetzt auch das
video einfach weiter welche schule bist
du gegangen ich bin tatsächlich aufs
gymnasium gegangen habe dort mein abitur
gemacht und bin danach auf eine
fachhochschule gegangen und habe dort
meinen bachelor gemacht die bislang das
geilste was die mit sandra passiert ist
die sache ist wenn man mit sandra
unterwegs ist passieren so lustige dinge
wieder auf augenhöhe hast du eine
freundin nein das ist wirklich sehr sehr
traurig was wolltest du werden bevor du
youtube wurde ist klassisch wird youtube
heftig ich wollte tatsächlich architekt
werden wollte auch in die richtung etwas
studieren habe da auch praktika gemacht
aber ich bin happy
jetzt gerade mit youtube auch mit der
wohnung die ich ja gerade in hamburg bzw
die jetzt fertig ist kann ich auch
dieses architekten dingen dadurch dann
so ein bisschen aus leben kannst du mir
einen guten tee empfehlen ich bin in
letzter zeit tatsächlich sehr krass
einfach auf heißem wasser mit einer
zitrone drin hängen geblieben
kannst du bitte mal auf black pink
reagieren ja hätte ich bock drauf die
sache ist allerdings dass ich ja nicht
die rechte daran habe und dann das video
gesperrt werden hier wasserfall mal
wieder am start hast du eine idee wie
man aus freund ein paar wird nein
kann ich nicht sagen ich bin selber
single wie viel ist dein outfit werd
mich bei im normale tennissocken an ich
habe eine frau die hosen für 20 euro
haben t shirt an für fünf euro
youtube man die regelt welche modemarke
feierst du am meisten kannst du nicht
grüßen heiße maxime erstmal ganz liebe
grüße wachstum ich hoffe ihr jetzt gut
und die modemarke dich am meisten feier
als schöpfung
was würdest du personen sagen die
gemobbt werden ich glaube ich würde in
erster linie erstmal der person etwas
sagen die mod also die die person halt
mops und zwar eine ordentliche ansage
weil ich kann es überhaupt nicht
nachvollziehen wie man 19 morgen kann
und sich daran auf geld anderer leute zu
beleidigen soll ich verstehe das prinzip
von mobben einfach nicht aber was ich da
bei einer person dann sagen würde die
gemobbt wird wäre glaube ich einfach
herrscht darüber und es ist auch nicht
für immer also dass meisten mobbing
passiert glaube ich in der schulzeit und
die endet halt irgendwie nach der
zwölften klasse wenn man 18 ist oder so
hat man noch so viel vom leben vor sich
und dann kann man komplett anderer
mensch sein also stay strong würdest du
dir vorstellen mit sandra einer
beziehung sein könntest du vegan leben
ja ich habe tatsächlich vor einigen
wochen monaten habe ich tatsächlich mal
für mehrere wochen lang vegan bzw
vegetarisch gelebt und ich hab's auch
gut hingekriegt allerdings ist es jetzt
gerade bei mir so dass sich halt für
viele sachen wo ich früher einfach
fleisch das habe zum beispiel morgens
irgendwie wurst oder irgendwie so offen
brötchen nämlich mittlerweile irgendwie
er marmelade oder nutella oder keine
ahnung irgendwie was aber jetzt wenn ich
dann in die abends mit der familie essen
bin dann esse ich schon mal ab und zu
irgendwie ein steak oder so ich bin dass
kein vegetarier ich will auch kein
veganer habe ich versuche schon sehr
krass darauf zu verzichten auch komplett
auf milchprodukte und so date ist du im
moment jemanden nein
ich bin absolut single weißt du dann
deine freunde geburtstag haben neben der
schlechteste mensch was geburtstage
märkten angehe warum hast du dich noch
nicht den laser luca umbenannt und wann
kommt wieder broll star als erst mal
ganz kurz zu groll stars ich bin ich hab
19.000 trophy war richtig girl talk hier
aber eher mit laserdrucker unbedingt ich
habe tatsächlich überlegt mich mal auf
youtube in den namen laser luca
umzubenennen aber bis jetzt noch nicht
gemacht weil ich finde namen luca
irgendwie cool finde bei laserdruckern
auch cool weil es irgendwie mehr so mein
eigener name ist und ich brauche auf
instagram tik tok et cetera heiß aber
was haltet ihr davon schreibt mir gern
und in die kommentare
mit wie vielen jahren hast du mal
ausprobiert zu rauchen mit 18 direkt und
dann direkt aufgehört weil scheiße ist
falls gar nicht erst alles ist so
ekelhaft wie findest du kapital braas
pizza ich finde sie eigentlich gut also
im vergleich zu einigen anderen pizzen
ist sie auf jeden fall besser aber es
ist halt so eine american style pizza
und das finde ich nicht so sehe mich
eher wird sondern italienischen pizza
mit dünnem boden 17 stück holt das
fließt so richtig runter der käse und da
bin ich zum sc fan von das ist
geschmackssache lauten monte bist du ein
alkoholiker weil du jedes wochenende
trinkst würdest du dich selbst so
bezeichnen also ich glaube monte hat das
ja generell irgendwie mal gesagt und
nicht auf mich gezogen weil ich trinke
nicht jedes wochenende
ich trinke jeden tag ich will mich jetzt
nicht alkoholikern denn also alkoholiker
sind für mich leute die ohne alkohol
nicht leben können genauso
drogenabhängige sind leute die ohne
drogen nicht leben können und ich trinke
ab und chance genutzt zum beispiel
gestern hat eine freundin ihre bachelor
mit abgegeben darauf haben wir
angestoßen haben wir gestern gedrungen
am freitagabend aber heute jetzt nicht
weil verkatert dass ich um gottes willen
kein alkoholiker was ist dein lieblings
alkoholgetränke perfekt da sitzt danach
direkt an so eine frage kommt ich würde
sagen gin tonic ganz klassische sonic
warum sagst du immer nur schlechte
sachen über dich du bist nicht schlecht
erstmal danke aber ich glaube das ist
einfach ein großer teil meines humors
dass ich mich einfach selbst auf die
leichte schulter nehme mich selbst
irgendwie oft verarschen ich glaube
damit hängt auch ein bisschen zusammen
hattest du eine zeit lang angst vor
corona jahr safe
also direkt als diese ganze sache halt
hoch kam irgendwie januar februar märz
um den dreh hatte ich mega angst davor
weil er auch so eine extreme panikmache
auf einmal in der bevölkerung am start
war mir den ganzen hamsterkäufen und so
wie jetzt gerade liebt man halt einfach
damit so es gibt jetzt immer mehr
lockerungen und jetzt gerade nicht mehr
so krass ehrlich gesagt aber man sollte
es wirklich nicht unterschätzen
anders stellt mich dass heute wieder ist
alex abend meine lieben freunde ich
hoffe euch hat es gefallen dass ich mal
wieder so ein paar fragen beantwortet
haben weil viele arme letzten wirklich
einfach geschrieben auf instagram und so
hey du machst einen container wieder was
über dich hören manchmal hier bisher
ruhig gefallen hat was lag da folgten
auf instagram ich als laser luca grad
neues bild hochgeladen und jetzt
befinden es auch schon im auto meine
lieben freunde ich oben für den smiley
angewendet wenn noch kein teil der lupus
main kanal noch nicht abonniert
praktiker gern drauf ist kostenlos und
verpasst keine videos mehr und hier ist
ein video verlinkt was soeben auf meinem
speed kanal online gegangen ist
mit sandra angucken
[Musik]